Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live.
Before we get started, I wanna thank my
employer Equinix Medal. They provide the time for
me to invest and to produce in this
material so that we can all learn together.
If you want to try out the platform,
please use the code Rawkode Live. This will
give you $50 of credits. You can splurge
that all in a few hours with some
beefy hardware with 400 terabytes of RAM, 400
gigabytes of RAM, would be a clever trick
and loads and loads of CPUs or you
could use it more wisely. I prefer the
former.
We're gonna take a look at OpenTelemetry
today. So I'm going to invite my wonderful
guests now.
Hello
Amy Toby and Liz Fong Jones. How are
you both today? Hello. Hello. I'm doing good.
Good and alright. There we go.
So
let's start with you, Amy. I like alphabetical
order lists. Can you just tell us who
you are, who you work for, and then
we'll move on to Les, and then we'll
get started with today's episode.
Alright. I'm Amy Toby. I've been in in
SRE since before it was called that, about
twenty years now. I work at Equinix Metal
with David, but in I am a principal
SRE in our software engineering group.
Okay. And Liz?
Hi. I'm Liz Fong Jones. I'm a principal
developer advocate at Honeycomb.io.
We are a company that helps developers understand
their software and how it's behaving in production,
and I am a contributor to OpenTelemetry.
Which is great because today, we're talking about
OpenTelemetry.
Could we maybe spend then the next, let's
say, couple of minutes and just kinda cover
what OpenTelemetry
is and what problem it's trying to solve?
Absolutely.
So OpenTelemetry
is a solution to the problem that previously
there were a number of different ways that
you could use to try to get your
data from your application into
platforms that could help you understand what was
going on.
So you can think of everything from New
Relic to Datadog to Splunk to kind of
more upstart modern tools like Honeycomb. Right? Like,
all these tools have their own kind of
explorers,
their own SDKs.
And, therefore, there is a high barrier to
kind of adding one to try it out,
to switching, to experimenting.
And each of us who are on the
vendor side had to reimplement the same kind
of SDKs to collect trace data, to kind
of
to to instrument
to instrument frameworks.
So
we all decided, basically, back in
at at the end of 2018, actually, we've
been on this journey two years now,
to merge all of our open source efforts
and to combine them together into something called
OpenTelemetry.
So you may have heard of OpenTracing or
OpenCensus. Those are kind of the two predecessor
projects to OpenTelemetry.
But OpenTelemetry's
goal is to kind of unify all of
this that there's just one perspective on how
to do it and not three.
Awesome. Alright. So
let's
we have a couple of comments. So we
got
Waleed saying hello. Hello, Waleed. Sayam, thank you
for joining us again.
Now
the
the premise of this show is generally that
we try to do very little upfront. I
like everything to happen in front of the
viewer's eyes.
And I think that's really important because, like,
you know, Amy and I as principal engineers,
you know, we like to demonstrate to people
that, you know, hey. We as principal engineers
sometimes struggle with syntax. We as principal engineers
have our compilers, like, not work. Right? Like,
those are things that happen to everyone. We're
not, you know, perfect human beings just because
we're principal engineers.
I got some inkling, so I did cheat
a little bit and ran through some stuff.
But I think David's starting with a a
blank slate. So hope hopefully, we just eliminate
the the the really tedious bits.
Well, mean I think we're gonna up the
ante a little bit with this episode because
not only are we starting from mostly fresh
slate and I'll cover them mostly in a
second, but we're all working with a repository
that we have no experience with essentially. And
I don't think any of us are particularly
familiar with the project we're gonna use. So
let's cover the context then.
So
this is the I opened the wrong tab.
This is supposed to be tankerbell.org.
Okay, the problem.
Which
is a provisioning platform for bare metal and
Tinkerbell aims to solve the problem of I
have a bare metal machine, I wanna spin
it up, get an operating system on it
and make it available for someone to use
and provision their own software.
Now there's quite a lot involved with this,
there are many moving parts. So we're gonna
focus on
two aspects of it today hopefully,
which is if I move over here
and pull up the read me and the
tank CLI and the tank server.
Now these are the smallest kind of surfaces
that we can work on. The tank CLI
gives us some commands that we can run
that speaks to the tank server over gRPC.
Hopefully all very easy for us to instrument
with OpenTelemetry to a certain degree.
But there's still a lot of complexity in
this project as a whole. Now we got
very lucky and that a colleague of Amy
and I's Jason has worked on a tilt
file which I'm using today.
Tilt is amazing. I love it.
Yes. So this is the bit that has
not merged into the main branch yet
but it is available for everyone to use
and the reason I did this upfront is
that there's a whole bunch of dependencies that
happen in the background
lots of cache stuff that needs to be
available in Docker images. I don't really wanna
make everyone sit and watch this for twenty
minutes while it's spun up. So I have
done this upfront, I do apologize but we
are in a position now where we can
make changes to the CLI and the server
components and the auto live reload. That is
all I've done and like this will be
available on the main branch soon and to
make sure that worked, I did what any
senior developer would do and added a print
to standard out called help me too.
So I Hope I'm trapped in the server
factory.
And you can see hopefully if we've got
this right, if I just remove the two
then tell as amazing as it is detects
that change, rebuilds image, redeploys it and we
can see the help me is now available
here. So that's all we have done up
front. What that means is we have a
feedback loop for making changes to this, which
I'm hoping
is enough for you to to be able
to guide us through the process of adding
OpenTelemetry to this project. Does that all sound
good?
Great. Sounds perfect. We're all about short feedback
loops here at HoneyGo.
Awesome.
Alright. Well,
let's start then with
what is the first step, you know, as
someone working on a project
has this great idea. I wanna add OpenTelemetry
to it. What what is step one? What
what do we do here? Step one would
be, why don't we go through and look
at a sample Go application,
a sample Go server, that's a gRPC server,
to understand how does OpenTelemetry instrumentation work.
So if you go to
github.com/open-telemetry/opentelemetry-go,
without the dash this time. I know. We
couldn't get OpenTelemetry,
the GitHub name. Someone had squatted it.
If you're out there and you hear that
your organization owns Open dash or OpenTelemetry, one
word, we want to hear from you. Okay.
And now go to example.
And let's go pull up the gRPC server.
So it's under basic.
Basic.
And look at main.go.
I think this is it.
No. This one doesn't have the gRPC. There
is oh, I know where we moved that
to. We moved that to OpenTelemetry
Go contrib because
it's
we didn't want to make everyone importing OpenTelemetry
import all of import all of gRPC.
So now let's go to
instrumentation gRPC.
GitHub's run? Yep.
Yep. Probably there. Yep. Example.
Perfect.
And server.
Okay. So let's look at what a sample
application that's a gRPC application
instrumented with with OpenTelemetry looks like.
So here's the standard,
you know, say hello
open open
standard gRPC code for saying say hello.
So what you'll notice is that we haven't
actually changed the code very much for that.
But what we have changed is that we've
changed the instantiation of the gRPC server.
So if you scroll down,
you should see
that there is
it's still all boilerplate boilerplate.
Right there.
That we've configured a stream interceptor
that will automatically
create trace spans anytime a request is received
in the server.
So that's what we're going to need to
add to our gRPC instantiation
inside of inside of Tinkerbell.
Okay. So
just so that I understand that correctly then
is the OpenTelemetry,
when we add it to our Go package
as a dependency, it provides especially
the gRPC stuff just provides hooks that we
can just add to the server definition
that does all the instrumentation for us. Like,
we don't have to manually go an instrument
any of our gRPC functions or anything like
that. It adds the basic skeleton. Right? You
still have to add meat to the skeleton.
But if you don't have a skeleton, right,
like, your your body's gonna fall apart. Right?
So we kind of have Halloween. I know.
Day past Halloween, we can still be a
little spooky. Right? Like, if you don't have
a skeleton on the inside, like, everything's gonna
fall apart. Right? So either you can add
that skeleton by hand, or you can have
something helpful like hotel gRPC add the skeleton
for you. So the skeleton here is skeleton.
The skeleton here is RPC calls coming in
and leaving. Right? So when you issue an
RPC call, you want to have that instrumented.
When you receive an RPC call, you want
to have that instrumented as, hey. This is
a trace scan. This is your network.
What's not done automatically for you is adding
data on kind of some of the attributes
of what's happening. For instance, things like what
is the request
what server did you request? Right? What size
of server did you request?
Or where is the server located? Right? Like,
those are parameters that the generic framework cannot
possibly know about, so you have to manually
add them. Similarly, in the same way to
how we kind of added the help help,
right, like, into the into the console
output,
you can choose to add kind of logging
messages or up and attach them to trace
spans. Those are all things that you can
do, but you have to have a trace
span that's already instantiated to add those attributes
or or log events to.
Okay.
So
now we have to do this over here.
So let me to see
this is the server.main.go.
Now this is it? Yeah. This is. If
I had to guess, it's under a gRPC
server.
G r p ah.
Okay.
So we should see something that looks like.
Yep. Right there. Set up gRPC.
Right. GRPC new server.
Right. Okay.
So
do we have we need to then start.
I'm assuming we have to add something to
our goal dot mod that that tells it
to bring or just add the import to
the top of the file to tell it
to bring in the OpenTelemetry
code. That's correct. So if you go back
over to the exam,
you can see what the import is for
hotel gRPC.
Yep. Perfect. That'll do it.
I'm gonna not save that because I'm pretty
sure if I do, VSCool is gonna remove
it.
It's thinking about it. So helpful.
So helpful.
Okay. And then let's add the interceptor. Again,
you can basically
you can basically cut paste that. Oh, just
do that. Okay. So we want to
can I just copy all of that? So
you'll notice that when it says gRPC new
server, the interceptors
are passed as parameters to the new server,
whereas you're programmatically
constructing your list of server arguments in your
application. So you'll copy the gRPC lines here,
the stream interceptor and unary interceptor.
But where you paste them is not going
to be into gRPC new server
because
do you see, like, params..dot?
So you need to add to that params
list.
Ah. Yep.
So are we gonna call You already have
a from me? I
think it should coexist. I think you can
have more than one interceptor.
Does
the order matter? So so this is gonna
go, like, be in the call stack. Right?
Like, when the request comes in, gRPC is
gonna go through this list and call each
of these interceptors and pass it some data.
Mhmm. So we probably want it after that
TLS setup thing or before.
Like See, it works fine with permissive. It's
it'll work fine here. Right? Like, the credentials
are are automatic. Right? Or sorry. The credentials
are done on on init. Right? The credentials
are not per request. That should be fine.
Okay. Okay. So now if you save this
and then comment it oh, in fact,
the s code is detected and added it
already. Perfect.
Okay.
So that's great. But now in addition, what
we need to configure is we need to
configure a
exporter.
We need to configure an exporter so that
we can see where this output is going.
Versus code is is
Well, Versus code has gone a little rampant.
What?
Okay. We're good. We're good? Yeah. I didn't
touch it. Okay.
So first, let's check, make sure that it
compiles as is.
It's currently
building. Oh, we have a restarting
field container.
I think that was just that weird moment
where we had that weird paste three times
and I think we're Oh. They just back
up again.
Your database schema is out of date.
If that's just a a warning, we can
ignore that one. I've already
ignored that one.
Okay. Interesting.
We have a small problem.
Boots and oh, team server. I
mean, that's gonna show me the same that
I got anyway, but I'll just double check.
Make the same change locally and see what
it does.
Live debugging.
Live debugging is excellent.
Nothing ever works the first time.
No. Of course not.
So I just remove it. We'll make sure
that it goes back to a healthy state,
which
ah, I have insufficient
CPU potential. No.
I think I've found our one of our
problems.
Oh, it's serving now?
Yeah. But I removed the gRPC hotel stuff.
So So here's the other thing that we're
missing. There are some common init stuff that
we did
in the hotel con in the hotel config
in the example app that you have not
yet done here. So if you go back
to GitHub, and do you see where it
says config.init?
That is doing some boilerplate that we need
to also add.
So let's go look where that comes from.
So that comes from
it's common init code shared between the client
and server. So, yep,
that may be able to take you directly
there if GitHub let you.
Perfect.
So
this is the stuff that we also need
to put in,
except for this. This stuff is not specific
to gRPC. So instead of putting it in
the gRPC code, you should put this in
your main function.
So
you can literally just sleep all of that
in it,
and I would, like, call a function called
o Telenet or something. That way it's, like,
nicely modular and put it in your main
function.
Okay. So we go to our tank server
main. We're gonna drop in this edit function.
We're gonna give it a slightly better name.
Yep.
And let's see if that says.
Okay.
So
maybe missing a few things.
Yep. You're probably missing every single one of
those imports.
And even if you aren't, even if Odell
was not or even if the ESCO is
not able to figure it out, it'll resolve
the duplicates, so you'll be fine.
Yeah. I'm hoping when it saves, it'll just
yep. Yep. There you go.
Yeah. Wasn't able to figure out SDK trace.
So, unfortunately,
we have two packages named trace in OpenTelemetry.
One of them is SDK trace and the
other one is API trace.
So, therefore,
the name trace is not necessarily an ambiguous.
That's why we have SDK trace.
So this is actually a great opportunity to
talk about the difference between the API and
the SDK in hotel.
The API is what you use when you're
instrumenting your code. Right? So let's just say,
you know, this is a span, this is
a child span,
whereas the SDK is something that you configure
once per process initialization.
And the SDK is the thing that keeps
track of where am I writing out data.
Right? Like, what are my configuration options? Right?
So your application code doesn't need to worry
about the SDK except for in the one
place where you're where you're initializing your system
and configuring it.
And this means that libraries don't need to
have a
a OpenTelemetry
SDK. They just need to call the API.
So that's something I want to
get you to talk a little bit Liz,
was
so if what you just said means we
can start to lay in OpenTelemetry into this
open source software, and it can lay dormant
until somebody wants to turn it on or
hook it up to
Honeycomb or
LightStep or whatever. That's correct.
That's cool.
Okay. So does anyone know why my fatal
is showing me
Probably because your log package is not necessarily
the same log package package as as we're
as we're expecting. Just
see what autocomplete tells you that logger can
Oh, try logger.fatal.
You
have a logger here, so let's let's use
your logger. But that's initialized too. I guess
we can pass it into the hotel in
it. Right? So Sure.
Yep.
I don't go very often. Does someone wanna
take over for this little bit? What file?
I think Amy just volunteered. Go ahead. Which
file is that? Main go. Main dot go.
Yeah. So I guess we'd have to say
log and then put in a type or
You don't want log. That's going to cause
a type collision.
Yeah. I'll grab it in just a second.
Where's the interface?
Logger.
Pointer? Let's go pointer.
So while you're doing that, we did have
a question Yep. It'll work. A question if
we can tackle that right now.
Wait. Is it logger.logger,
or is it log.logger?
Pretty sure the package name is Logger is
loaded.
Let me fix it. No. But the the
package name for log for the capital l
logger is log.
The package name is log.
Is it?
Oh, I see. I see. Right.
We have a question saying if you have
the Prometheus interceptors not not enough, can it
feed OpenTelemetry?
Yes and no. Prometheus
can feed its metrics into the OpenTelemetry
collector to produce metrics,
But this should bring us to an excellent
occasion to talk about the difference between a
metric and a trace.
A metric is a pre aggregated point of
data. Right? Like, it's like a gauge that's,
you know, amount of CPU used or,
you know, amount of disk space used.
A or it's a counter, like number of
requests received.
Whereas tracing is a lot more granular. The
Prometheus exporter, by definition, is not capable of
producing
that fine grade data about the execution of
every request. I can tell you how many
requests you got, but, like, not how each
request executed.
So Prometheus
usage is not incompatible with OpenTelemetry. Right? Like,
you can feed Prometheus metrics into the hotel
collector onto your metrics platform
of choice. It's just that, you know, you
you would rather part of why we're going
through this exercise is to get that higher
granularity data.
Excellent. And I think
Amy's code has now got the hotel in
it happy.
So I'm assuming we can
after our logger here, let's just Yeah. With
the help me. We don't need Yeah. That
verification anymore as that we can just pass
in logger.
Yep.
I think that should do it.
Oh, I
think you want
I don't know if it needs to be
a pointer, but it'll do for now.
It's not Sure. Why not? Anymore, so I'm
not gonna complain. Okay. So that looks like
Versus code is happy, which is usually a
good indicator. I'm happy when it's happy. So
What does still think?
Let's pop over to tilt at
Tilt's always so critical.
We have a restart and failed container.
Did did it just build?
So it's currently
in this orange. Okay. Yeah. So it may
oh, wait. Wait. What was it?
K.
That might be it. Let's see. Alright. So
what's it complaining about? It's saying new config
file found, but that's info level.
Do we have the pod logs? Do the
pod logs tell us that there's, like, some
kind of a crash or something?
Okay. Let's take a look at that. So
we can do let's get pods.
Let's grab the most recent one. I think
that should match with what we get there
so we can try describe and see if
there's any other information.
Yeah. It looks like it is just crashing.
There is a Well, there are logs and
metrics. This would be so
easy.
So we're not really getting anything useful.
Now if we take out
and it
does well, if we take out the the
g r p c stuff, it does work.
So I'm trying to work out It it
does with the build it out there. Okay.
So we were able to run OTELLONIT, but
not the gRPC interceptor.
Can we can we try that to verify?
We can try that. So let's Yes. Let's
take out the gRPC interceptors.
Oops. You commented out one too many lines.
Yep. There we go. Okay. So let's try
that to see whether we're at least able
to initialize the hotel boilerplate.
Yep. It's green. It's health it's healthy.
Interesting.
Okay. So there's something about the interceptor that
is not happy. So let's try the theory
that maybe
trying to have two different interceptors is not
working. So let's comment out that and then
comment this and see whether that works.
I clearly don't know enough about gRPC interceptors.
This is a research thing for me to
learn about more later. It's green. I think
it works.
Did it recompile already?
Yeah.
Okay. So the answer is you cannot have
more than one interceptor. GRPC will crash the
server
without an error message if you have more
than one interceptor. Okay. Great. So
now let's fire up the CLI,
and let's establish a connection.
Okay.
So
I I made a small just fail that
hits the server. So that is called a
hardware list.
So we should have
some
something somewhere.
Okay. Great. Let's find out whether we got
a gRPC
let's let's find out whether we got a
gRPC call
recorded to our terminal.
So let's go over to the That's file.
Yep. Uh-huh. Yes. We did.
Yay.
Okay. Could could could we cover that then?
So we are not actually writing
that trace anywhere. So by default, the interceptor
just drops that into standard out?
The interceptor does not, but the boilerplate, if
you go back to the boilerplate in the
In Yep. Main.
In main dot go,
what you'll see is that it's configured
to write to
it's it's configured to write to write to
standard out.
We can change that. We can send this
output to Honeycomb instead.
Amy, do you have the Honeycomb API key?
I do. Let's Okay. Why don't you research
why don't we go find the Honeycomb API
key? Got
it. I'll send it to David so he
can, like, not try not to put it
on the screen.
Yep. That that's that's alright.
We can work I can make that work.
I'll I'll Slack it to you in the
background. Okay. So what are the first steps
then to sending this to to Honeycomb?
Okay. So,
again,
like, we like to walk through the journey
as if we were a user. So I
happen to know this, but let's go ahead
to
GitHub Honeycomb v o
OpenTelemetry
export or go.
I I don't currently have admin, so that
is a API key I found. So if
we accidentally expose it, we're gonna have to
go bother people to clean it up. So
You can create a new you can create
a new API key. I can. Just create
a new write only API key, and then
it's fine if it appears on stream.
It's
k. Alright. So just set that up. I
must be a team owner to create and
edit API keys.
Okay. Why don't I sneak Let me let
me just give me a second. I might
go get this one real quick.
I know people.
Although he's offline. So
Alright. I'm just gonna start copying the basic
code and see what happens. So Excellent.
That's how things are done these days. Yeah.
I'm okay with that bit.
Yep. It's completely normal for principal engineers to
do.
So you copy the case to me, but
then you kinda hammer on it for a
while, make it look okay.
Does this code go in our hotel in
it then and not in the gRPC stuff?
Yep. I'm assuming we maybe replace this part
here.
Let's mark this out for now.
Yep.
Similarly, your dataset.
Don't turn on with debug enabled. We already
have
we already have, whatchamacallit,
standard out output. So
we don't we don't also need this,
and it's a handy demonstration.
Okay. But I do need the bracket. What's
your team name? Is it Equinix?
Yeah.
Great.
Okay. So now I need to understand what
that honeycomb is. So I'm just gonna copy
this URL
and hope that that magically does it.
And paste this and call this Yep. Honeycomb.
Yep.
I I also Oh, no. It's slash honeycomb.
It's slash honeycomb. Okay. Okay.
We took care of that for you. Yep.
Codependencies have always confused me. I try my
best.
Okay.
Finding an owner,
suing in as them.
He he's actually poking at it right now
too. Oh. So
Okay.
Great. In my case, I will leave leave
pseudo mode.
Okay. And you want to change your dataset
to be a descriptive dataset like OpenTelemetry Tinkerbell
or similar.
Yep. Or, like, dev Tinkerbell maybe since we're
using this for dev right now. You'll in
a production environment, you want to change this
to be configurable with a environment variable or
similar. But
and our service name is Tinkerbell.
But would would we wanna include things like
the environment name and stuff in that, or
would that just be the app and then
we could use other dimensions for, like You
probably want to have one dataset for environment,
so you would want to programmatically construct your
dataset name.
Okay. Can we kinda just break down some
of these terms, Jennifer?
Well, for me, that's not familiar. So when
we say dataset, based on the conversation that
you two are having, is that like a
table, a database, something that groups It's essentially
a database. Yes. It's a kind of unit
of of being able to look at your
data at least within Honeycomb.
So this concept does not necessarily have to
exist in OpenTelemetry,
which is why it's specific to the exporter.
Okay. And the service name, should that reflect
that this is the Tink server? Yes. Right.
Okay.
So we have our dev tanker bell database.
We're tagging these traces that they come from
a service called tank server. Yep.
We still have a little bit of red
squiggles. So let me see if I can
work that one out just now. So the
import seems to be okay, but this is
complaining.
Okay. So the dataset
Oh, it's because you already instantiated a another
exporter called standard out. So I would I
would, like, change exporter there just above to
say standard to say, like
yeah. So this is,
yep.
And then And then again there.
And then now
you want to pass another STD trace with
syncR,
Line 66. Yep. And pass in addition to
passing the standard out exporter, you want to
yep.
With
thinker,
and then we pass in our honeycomb. Right?
Yep. That's correct.
There you go.
That should roughly do it, and now we
just need that API key.
And as long as it's configured to be
a write only API key, it's safe to
expose it relatively straight to expose it on
stream, and you can just revoke it afterwards.
Worst case, someone writes, a hundred events into
your Honeycomb dataset.
Whatever.
Okay. So the Honeycomb exporter doesn't seem to
have a close. Can I just comment a
sec?
It should have a oh, that's out of
data documentation.
Let me see what that that ought to
be. I believe
that might be
let me check that. One second.
It does not have a close. It does
have a shutdown.
Okay. Shut down. Okay.
And I think
this is what we actually grabbed from the
honeycomb doc. So I'm gonna pull down the
other one, which I I think I just
got an update reference to.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yep. So that needs to
go down.
Yep.
And
You want that error nil above.
Because, otherwise, if creating the honeycomb exporter fails,
you want to have it fail out before
you
Sorry. Can you say that again? The line
65 to 67, move that above the instantiation
of the trace provider. Because, otherwise, if the
honeycomb
order instantiation
fails,
you want to know about it before you
Yeah. You have you have it stubbed to
underscore on the That means the context. Yep.
Yep. Background context is fine.
Why is it not
You don't have it loaded yet.
Or no. It's context. Like, context dot.
Okay. There we go. Oh,
that's not completed Do
we have the API key?
Yeah. David has it. You you can paste
that one.
I'm gonna add Did you send that? So
I can clean it up too. Yeah. Just
I just slapped it to you.
Okay. Do you want me to just paste
it in?
I'll just move this over here.
And this is a write only one, I
can share it, or do you want me
to
It is
no. It's fine for now. Yeah. I'll I'll
If there is a problem with it, we'll
forgive it on the back end. Don't worry
about it.
Alright. So I've dropped it in,
and I have closed that file. So we
can't open that file anymore. And if we
do, we'll just deprecate the key later. So
it's okay. Yep. Okay. Great. So now
let's go to tilt
and
having hit the having hit the endpoint.
So Yep. Okay. So we're serving. We successfully
in the Honeycomb Explorer. It hasn't failed. So
let's call the endpoint.
Oh.
Oh, try again, I think.
Yeah. There we go. Better. Okay.
Where is my email?
Gonna try to add David real quick to
an email. So if I understand what's just
happened there, we've added the Honeycomb exporter
to the gRPC plug in, and it's now
writing the trace data when we ever whenever
we had the tank server gRPC API and
sending that to Honeycomb.
That is correct.
Okay.
Unfortunately,
I am not yet seeing your data on
the back end, so let's see whether there's
any errors or anything.
Oh,
that doesn't look good. That sounds like we
have some kind of fatal error.
Oh, yep. Here we go. So our tell
is telling us that something went wrong.
Oh,
your defer is bad.
Oh.
I see the problem.
So what happened it out for now. Right?
Like, it's not the end of the world.
Yeah. You want to move that stuff into
your shutdown sequence.
Right? The problem is that it deferred at
the end of your main function, whereas your
main or, like, your
does that make sense? So the The defer
runs at the end of the function it's
in. Yeah. And you want you want it
on the to to run at the end
of main instead. Yep.
Okay. Do you wanna you wanna move that
to fair, and I'll just leave my screen
away from it because we have the token.
Have you got to print out?
Let's do this. I mean, you don't have
to run it.
You do not have to run it. However,
if you have a a graceful shutdown,
right, the idea is you don't want to
lose your traces that are in flight. Okay.
Where are we at? We're in hotel and
So
Yeah. You may need to make otal on
that return the honeycomb object or return, like,
a shutdown hook.
I was just gonna paste it in here
for now. So root command execute.
Right. That should be fine for now. Right?
It's not oh, oh, okay. I see.
Okay. Now I understand. Yes. Because we we
put it in the yeah. Okay.
Fun.
Fun. Fun. Fun.
Oh, my key key repeat still isn't working.
What's the type on that anyway?
It should be a
might be a.
It's a Honeycomb dot exporter.
The honey
Honeycomb dot exporter.
So what was the problem when we moved
the defer line down? It sounds like it
got a little bit more complicated. Because the
defer was was
wait. Oh,
right. There there we go.
That should do it.
So the defer was inside of our hotel
init function, but the hotel init function returns
control to the main function immediately.
Okay. The defer needs to make sure that
happens as part of cleanup after the rest
of main finishes.
So we needed to hoist the the close
function out.
Okay. So now we've done that. I think
that should work.
Alright. Well, our tank server
Is running. Sorry for Elite. We're not showing
the codes just because the API token was
there, but I will push this code to
my fork with the API key removed so
you can see that hotel in it function.
Don't worry.
Now the tank server says it was restarted
two minutes ago.
So have we definitely saved that file and
triggered a rebuild or is it just tell
is
I mean, I did it colon w.
You may need to trigger, like, an innocuous
change to some other file,
or you yeah. You can just press the
I'll just force a rebuild. We'll see what
happens here. So let's give that a couple
seconds.
It's now
running.
So if I run this again,
and it's pretty consistently now Now it's reliable.
Okay. I
see data. We have data. Okay. Yep. We
have data. David, I sent you an invite.
It should only take you a second if
you want to log in to Honeycomb.
It should be in your Equinix email.
Okay. No problem.
Let's look at some of these traces. So
earlier,
we were looking at the traces in, like,
a text format, like, not super informative.
So the goal here of using a visual
tool like Honeycomb or if you want pure
open source, Yeager,
etcetera, right, the beauty of this is you,
you know, can use the same instrumentation with
multiple different back ends.
Then you can see
in a little bit more detail what's going
on rather than just having the things printed
out to standard out.
Okay. So while I'm just quickly signing up
for the honeycomb thing here,
right now, we're instrumenting the gRPC server.
Mhmm.
Now
we if we wanted to track that trace
from the CLI, is that something that would
be just as trivial to to kind of
add?
Yes. That's essentially correct. So, again, we're basically
following the
hotel gRPC example except for
you want to look at the client directory
instead.
Okay.
This is Honeycomb. You should be able to
see that now. Let me see if I
can just zoom in a little bit. So
how do I see this trace data that
we Scroll down to the bottom. It'll show
you, like, a list of recent traces, so
you can just open one of them.
And you may want to collapse the left
sidebar so it's a little bit
Oh, there we go. Down at the bottom.
There we go.
Ah. So yeah. So you can see here
that we have
that the name of the gRPC
call being made.
You can see how long it took.
You can see how long it took in
comparison to other traces of that same name
or other spans of that same name. If
you scroll down on the right hand side
by fields,
you should be able to see a couple
of other fields
indicating, you know, hey. I'm a tank server.
My status code was 0,
and so so on and so forth.
So
as you can see, it doesn't have very
many fields. Right? It's only what gRPC was
able to automatically infer. So that's where the
thing that I mentioned about, you know, providing
additional information about the client or about the
request being made could be helpful here.
Okay. So as a how how would I
add extra context to that trace? Great. That's
a wonderful question. So let's pull up the
RPC handler.
Okay. So here.
Is this what you meant? Sorry.
No. The RPC handler for that get all
call.
Alright. Okay. Gotcha. Okay. So we wanna jump
into the hardware,
and it is this push call here is
what we triggered, I believe.
Oh, no. We did a list, didn't we?
No. You yeah. You did you did a
list.
Oh, there it is.
Yep.
Okay. Interesting. You do have a database, it
looks?
Yes. So that speaks to Postgres
database. It speaks to Postgres. Great. So
one thing that we'll do, maybe if we
have a little bit of extra time, I
don't want to do the CLI instrumentation today.
I don't think that's going to be as
useful for your viewers.
I think that the interesting thing would be
to instrument all handler, and then also if
we can instrument the database calls underneath it
so you can see out of the total
length of time that this is taking, how
much is in the database and how much
is in your opcode.
Okay.
Great.
So
if we pull up the documentation
for OpenTelemetry
so if you go to
in your browser
to
go.OpenTelemetry.i0
and go to the hotel, which is the
API documentation,
and go to subdirectories
trip API trace.
API trace.
Yep. There we go.
Perfect.
So now you can see all of the
things that are valid to do.
Now the first thing that you want to
do, remember that gRPC automatically set up for
us
the
the tracing of my request.
So that means that what we have to
do we don't have to instantiate any new
spans, but we have to find the
span, the hotel span that was created for
us. So for that, we need span from
context. So let's go look at the Go
documentation for span from context.
That one. Perfect.
Yep. So you want to call
go to OpenTelemetry.i0/hotel
API trace,
and you want API and you want trace
dot span from context and run it on
your current context that gRPC has passed you,
and it will give you an hotel span
object,
which has been helpfully shoved in the context.
So let's see what that might look like
in action.
So at the top of your function,
is your context object?
I'm
assuming it may be on the server.
Yeah. It's probably
Get workflow front? No. That won't be able
to.
This is where my gRPC knowledge fades off
a little bit. I think server is
it was in
we were just looking at it.
Yeah.
It's in gRPCserver.com,
and it does not have a context object.
So
where does that all get called?
I presume the
No. We we previously removed the Prometheus
thing from this, and I do see Prometheus
code here. So would that help us understand
where the context is if we look at
this Prometheus code, or is that No.
The Prometheus package may have its own way
of passing the the info. So,
normally,
like, I'm looking at at some example code,
and it looks like if you need a
context,
you should just make context the first
the the the first
method the first
thing that you take in your signature. Yeah.
That's what the I was just looking the
rest of the functions are doing, so I
can add that. Yep. Okay.
So we just add this context here and
g r p c c t x space
context c context dot. Yeah. Okay. Context.
Okay. So now you have your context. So
at the very top of your function, before
you do anything else, you probably want to
get the tray the tracer.
So
so remember, it's
it's trace dot
trace dot trace from connex.
Not not it's not a method of the
of the GoConnex. It's a method of o
of hotel trace. Oh, the hotel one. Okay.
Alright. Yep. So
hotel.trace.
Sorry. It should just be trace dot.
Yep.
Trace from contact
or spam from context.
No. That's all I have access to.
Yeah. It's I think it's using the wrong
trace.
Okay. Just just start typing span from hot
next or
yeah. There oh, I see. There's runtime trace.
Oh, I I delete that. It's it's it
picked up the wrong import. That's why. Okay.
Okay. So in your imports, let's let's just
do this now.
In your imports at the top.
Okay. So let's import
go.opentelemetry.i0/hotel/API/trace.
Great. Okay. Now we have the correct trace.
Hopefully, it doesn't delete it. I've not solved
it. So Okay.
Good.
You're mistyping.
Let's see if we get
there we go. Yay.
Okay.
Yep. Check the API docs. I think it
may potentially
error.
Yeah. I'm just pulling that back up.
It should be Oh, no. It just returns
spam. Great. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. We've sent it
using.
So now
we can add attributes. What are some useful
properties of this that may be helpful? Let's
let's add something saying the number of results.
That seems like a useful thing to do.
K. So we have the So at the
bottom
Yep. And then we do hardware.
We make a list. So right after that
error, we can go
Yep. So here, spin set attribute, I believe.
Attributes?
Yep. Set attributes.
And this takes a
OpenTelemetry
key value pair list.
So OpenTelemetry has it, like, you know, because
that was silly.
OpenTelemetry has its own key value pair
kind of yep. Is it
I think it's just
API.
I think it's in the API package.
Oh, okay. Do we need to import that
or let us Yeah. You'll need to import
it.
Just one level up from trace. Just l
tell slash API?
It's slash label.
Oh,
somebody
deleted me.
Yeah. I think just don't save the file,
and it should hopefully stay.
In no. It's not even under API. It's
just hotel slash label.
It did it again. It's second underscore. I
know.
It's the worst. It's the utter worst.
Alright. Well, maybe underscore once we've got some
coding.
Oh, it's label.
Okay. I'll remove it. Okay. You should be
good.
So
I'm importing from label dot?
Yep. And then label dot int.
So
capital I int.
Yep. And then now you pass the name
of the key, which is going to be
probably, like,
num results or something.
People in Honeycomb usually standards upon
either camel case or underscores. It doesn't really
matter which you pick. Right.
And then you want to pass the length
of your list.
But we also had a comment from one
of our colleagues,
Manny, who said that we could have got
the context from stream dot context in the
old method rather than adding a new
a new variable to the signature. It's Lin,
not Link. Dirt.
Do I need to derep that?
It should be fine with the pointer, shouldn't
it?
Oh, that's a it's not a list. Dirt.
That that's a that's a proto.
Yeah.
But am I coming then? So
we do stream that sent. Oh, it doesn't
actually store them. It just streams them straight
out of the database, so we'll just add
a little counter.
Yep. So you may need to
yep.
Great.
Cool.
Okay. Great. So now if you call it,
you should start seeing
results
with
You should start seeing
in Honeycomb, you should start seeing, hey. There
are zero results, I guess, until you add
hardware to the list.
Okay. Well, the tank server seems happy now,
so let's jump back over here.
And it's all crashing. That's awesome.
Okay. Now let's go to Honeycomb.
And
Oh, there it is.
Go to Honeycomb homepage. It's easier.
Upper left hand corner.
There.
And let's go look at one of the
most recent requests, which is a few seconds
ago. Yep.
So now you can see on that span
that there are scroll down to the bottom
of your list there. Yep.
You should see
oh.
They did not show?
We do not see here
the
the new attribute that we added.
Oh,
is that code even actually called if there
are no results?
Good call.
Well, actually wait.
No. Error get get all.
Oh, wait.
It's calling a function, so it's sending a
closure over count. So is it actually gonna
count? It's gonna still count zero. So
Should still count zero. Still be sending it.
Right?
Because get all takes that function and then
calls it for each result.
Should we just confirm that we actually this
this is the function that's being called?
Yeah. That might be useful to do as
well
because we don't know for sure.
Yeah. Let me just see what else we
have here. But I I, yeah, I think
that all is definite hopefully, is what we're
we're calling. And we're run Well, I can
tell you that the OpenTelemetry side is fine.
So it's just a matter of are we
calling the calling it appropriately.
And, also, I guess, are we using the
correct context object?
But I'm pretty sure the one that Manny
said. Because we had a comment from our
colleague who says we should be using
equals stream
dot context. So maybe that's just the fix
there.
Oh, yeah. Okay. Let's try that.
Okay. So let's just rebuild that with till
it doesn't seem to notice the change in
this file. So it might just need to
retweak to the setup.
And that should be healthy again.
Yep. Alright. Let's call it.
Couple of calls.
Jump back over here.
Home page.
Oh, wait. That's too much. Nope. You want
the one from a few seconds ago. Yep.
This one here. Yep. That'll be
let's see.
No.
Direct. At hardware service slash all. Yeah. It
it is calling hardware service slash all.
Not
are we in the first file? Just something
silly at the top of the You could
add a logger there to make sure that
it's actually
calling this code.
Oh, like a span dot
it's like span dot log?
I'm
just saying about regular log. It doesn't depend
upon the OTO subsystem.
That way we know for sure.
Do we have a log global logger handle?
Or
no. You gotta grab it. Okay.
Got it.
Do you normally wrap up your stream after
an hour, like, on the dot, or do
you let it go long sometimes?
No. No. There's There's been some that I've
planned for an hour that have lasted two
and a half or three. So, like,
as long as you both have time, I'm
happy to Yeah. I have time. Let's let's
keep let's keep going. Let's
while we debug this, why don't we add
some database instrumentation too since we know that
the automatic instrumentation of gRPC at least is
working?
Okay.
So let's go to
once Amy is done here, we'll go to
the hotel contrib repo and have a look
at the documentation for
you're using the standard
database
classes
in in GoA?
Let's see.
Why is it complaining about label now?
Did we we did use label. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. It's complaining that actually. Oh. So
maybe that's our problem. Maybe that's why is
that is that it never picked up our
change because it never compiled.
But here's we're using it. So
It says no package for import. Go OpenTelemetry.io.
Can I see your go dot mod?
Actually, I'll go look at it myself. What's
your go mod say?
GoMod
says
where is your GoMod?
Wait. That's weird. Why am I not?
I may need to refresh my my share.
I think it's a little confused.
See.
Version 13. Yeah. That's correct.
Are you looking at it different way for
me? Because I don't see it.
It's I stopped complaining there, if that helps.
Oh. I think the s code may just
be
problematic day. Yeah.
But it's not complaining about label anymore.
We let's see. Did we add a logger?
We did add a logger to this function.
So I'm going to trigger a Yep. Let's
try it and see what happens.
Tilt.
And we'll see if we see what was
the log message called hardware all.
Alright. So it's running.
Alright. Let's hit the endpoint.
And I do not see
her message.
So it called
Interesting.
The service button. No.
Okay.
Now we know we've been instrumenting the wrong
function.
What the hell Alright. What else do we
have then? Let's see.
So if we come to the
command root, we've got the RPC servers here.
I mean, it looks like we're definitely modifying
the correct one.
RPC servers tanked g r p c, g
rpc,
hardware Go. I mean, I I don't see
how we've been getting getting that wrong.
Yeah. That seems
this seems very
surprising.
So what can we do?
Now our tell also stopped noticing changes,
which I'm gonna assume is maybe potentially
related. So I'm just gonna add a comment
to this file.
Yeah. That's not triggering.
Yeah. I think that's a little concerning because
I'm curious whether Tilt is even building the
right. Like, is Tilt even building the correct
files. Right? But we are seeing the hotel
stuff from the hotel in it. So
That's correct, but it broke a little while.
Right? Like, it broke a little while after
that. So Alright. Let's
let's tilt up again just in case.
So Alright.
Do you need to tilt stop first or
not? I just killed it.
Okay. Great. Great. Great. If I reload this
here,
we can see there's no bringing everything back
up. We'll need to wait till all of
this screen. Okay. Great. While we do that,
why don't we go ahead and look up
how to instrument databases?
And we So you said coworkers that I'm
missing stand up because this is more important.
We're we're missing an all hands too. So
You can watch the tape of all hands
afterwards. It's fine.
I'm
just gonna poke around here and see that
I can see then. What kind of keys
are those, Liz?
This is the terrible keyboard that I'm getting
rid of soon.
I do not recommend this keyboard. It is
a Rawkat keyboard,
and it unfortunately has a tendency to have
key presses duplicate,
which pisses the heck out of me. So
I actually have a set of
cherry drums
and on a on a keyboard coming soon
from from.
Okay.
So we want the SQL documentation.
I found this import. Yep. I haven't found
any documentation,
but
can I just browse to that?
You
should be able to find
oh,
I think that is a temporarily missing feature
gap. Actually, I'm not sure that we have
the SQL stuff instrument. So
Well, I will We can just go the
the database classes are pretty straightforward. It's not
a Oh, yeah. Let's let's demonstrate how to
add new spans. Perfect. Let let's do that
then. We
automatic information is fun, but let's let's do
manual instrumentation.
Okay. In our DB So I'm assuming I
pulled back up the hardware stuff, and we're
looking for
the DB calls. Right? Yep. Yeah. There's Where
it says DB get all? Yep. So let's
pop over there. Let's Which driver that instrumented?
Hardware here, hopefully.
Yep. There we go.
So there's all.
Okay.
So
here, it's, like, running a query, right, with
the context, which which is fine.
But my question is,
where is it instance dot query? Where's the
code for in for for instance query?
Let's find it.
And then
Like, what type is instance?
It can we hook in a little bit
lower down? Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Here.
This what you wanted?
Yep. But this looks like it's in go
it this is in Go's library. Oh, it
is. Yeah. Okay.
Okay.
We have a tank DB struct with an
instance on it. Oh,
that that's doable. That's doable. Okay. So if
you have a tank DB,
that means that
if someone runs query right?
Right. If if someone is running a query
on it, then they're going to call the
internal methods. Right?
So we can create a span every time
the query method is called on TinkDB because
TinkDB
implements
SQL DB, and that's what's being called. Right?
Okay. That makes sense.
Okay.
So
where is
where? I I don't see it. They're all
kinda open coded. Right? Like, they're
if you go into the hardware.go
Yeah. There's this here. It's They're just open
written queries. So Right. No. No. No. I'm
I'm seeing the query function. Where is the
query function implemented
on TinkDB?
If
we go back to TinkDB and search queries
directly on TinkDB. Is is a struct that
just has a SQL pointer.
Instances just it's just a SQL pointer. So
it's calling the Golang package. Oh, calling the
Golang package underneath immediately.
Yep. So I guess naively we could start
by instrumenting it directly here, but ideally,
that we should be adding another layer instead
of tank d b to proxy the queries
so the instrumentation could be in a single
place. Is that Yep. That's correct.
Although, like, as I said, once we get
the
your future request for your future request is
noted to get SQL DB in auto instrumentation
ported over.
We have not yet done that from OpenTelemetry
slash OpenTelemetry, but we will. Okay. So
see here,
where is our context?
The problem is we don't have a context
object here. Right? Like, that's that's the thing
that worries me.
Yeah.
We kind of need that context. Some of
them have it. Just that one that one
call doesn't.
Why does just get all not have it?
But, like, we can just change it. Right?
Like Yep. We can change it. I'm gonna
change it in hardware to test the context
and then Okay. I was able to once
have it. Okay. Yep. Yeah. Let's let's make
it always always take the context.
So let me
follow.
Oh, fairness info on that. It was did
he pass this by around his pointers or
just Nope.
Nope. It's always passed by Volley.
K. So there's context context. It should be
good now.
Okay. So we have a context. Did I
totally break the build?
I'm sure we'll find out.
It looks okay. We're good. Nope.
Build failed expecting
Oh, yeah. N 51.
Oh, why did it not change orange here?
Never mind.
Okay. Yeah. So it did fail.
Did I guess I'm running the context passing?
On line 51 gRPC server.
What?
Looks like we accidentally
one of us
bumped the key here.
Yep. That would do it.
Okay.
Back over to TinkDB.
Oh, now we've got more interesting.
Cannot use DB as type.
TinkDB does not implement.
Oh.
Wait. What? Yeah. So we do have a
a Versus code that is showing us an
error.
Do that instance dot query.
Yeah. See here, we've got it doesn't accept
with DB here.
Oh,
I see. When it's building us Oh, okay.
Back in here.
Let's
do a quick
diff on this file. I bet we accidentally
deleted something.
I'm not trying to do this quickly in
the s code.
David, I think we should just look at
a quick diff of what we've changed all
we've changed in gRPC server, and then we'll
quickly see what happened.
I've got too much going on here.
That's fair.
Yeah.
There we go.
Hey. Hey, Liz. There's a question about
how would we make sure logs events do
we already read that one?
Are are are during this request are correlated
with traces?
Ah, the log correlation?
Yes. So instead of using your logger,
what you want to use is something called
a span event.
So you can just call
span.ads
add span event and then pass your your
message.
So it's just a change from using your
standard logger to using a span event,
and it'll automatically make it a child of
the trace.
Db.database.
So d b
comes
through from in
root.co,
and it is passed in.
Well, I think this should be d What's
your type definition where where where where where
databases is defined? Maybe that's d b dot
instance. Yeah.
What what does server take? Oh, it's private.
You shouldn't have to change that. I think
it's the interface definition for DB.
Right? Like
yeah. So I I don't get why it
broke.
I understand why it broke because you added
context. Right? You added context and function signature.
There are some other interface definition presumably for
testability
where you need to make it take context
now.
Oh, because it it was passed in or
or did we In all the other in
all the other methods, it was. But you
need to so we can you search your
your code base
for get all? Like, search your code base
for get all.
There
we go. Yep. There you go. It's right
there.
Nice. That should do it.
Messaging return.
Oh, no. Wait. Let's see.
Is that it?
No.
Force to recompile,
but also look at main go line 74.
Yeah.
As you can see, a lot of the
fiddly stuff is not actually a hotel. It's
just like
Yeah. We we kind of
expected a little bit of the this code
to fight us a little bit.
A little bit of spaghetti. Yeah.
Oh,
propagators.
It's a return. Oh, honeycomb export.
Alright. Hey. Now the auto build is working
again, at least.
We're getting there.
It's happy.
Up backup restarting.
So
I just made up what I added to
here. Maybe we should just undo this a
few times. It looks like maybe
this was the changes that you both made
off screen.
Is that right? Have I made that That
that's that's correct. That's correct. Right? Like, because
we had to pass in the honeycomb Exporter
to be able to
You don't wanna return star Honeycomb Exporter, please.
Yeah. You want to return regular Honeycomb Exporter.
It's in
pink server main. What's the Oh, we need
to we need to return
Alright. This this function signature needs to return
a pointer, not a not a concrete honeycomb
exporter.
So go to the function signature here.
Alright. We
we do need to report return a pointer
to the x. Yep. Yep. Right. That's exactly
correct. And then
down here, we're gonna go return
we have a honeycomb Ampersand honeycomb explorer, I
bet.
Yeah. We'll need to delete that API key
afterwards too. Yep. And I'll do that as
soon as we hang enough.
Oh,
what?
That's just missing there.
Yeah. What's complaining about? How are these things
all getting, like, randomly It's a it's already
a pointer.
Okay. Yeah.
Because we're probably
Type it over each other, I think. It's
okay.
Alright. Let's see what happens now.
Running starts.
Let's see. Can I
no? Server's not running.
The only way of tracing. This would be
so much easier.
Back off restarting failed container.
First to rebuild?
Yep.
Yeah. So it's compelling, but it's just not
running.
Did we accidentally revert the change with the
interceptors?
Is that is that what's happening here?
Very possibly. GRPC?
Yep. It would be in gRPC. There.
Including commenting out the Prometheus.
But something did go weird with that code
at one just a few minutes ago, so
I don't remember what we did.
Yeah. The Prometheus Okay. That's still commented out.
Okay. That's good.
There was one there was one more line
in here. That's right.
That set up that that
it did something I thought was important. I
don't remember what it was.
Can you can you do a diff on
this section
real quick?
Let's fail this one.
Oh, the creds is missing.
Oh, yep. The creds are missing.
That would do it.
Oh my goodness. That
looks important.
Yeah. It looks important.
I have no idea how that lane disappeared,
but
then the
The v yeah. The the curly brace disappeared
at some point too, so must be all
these sharing and everything overlapping.
Yeah. Okay.
Grumble grumble.
So it's Alright. Let's rebuild and see what
happens.
And then we can get back to the
gap we are we are shaving, which was
which was instrumenting the database call.
Still getting the Still failing?
Why?
Let's diff can we diff everything we've done
so far?
Curious what that global diff looks like.
Alright. So that's just the tank fail.
Main Go add it at OpenTelemetry.
Yeah. That looks fine.
Okay. Yeah. That differs in the main, so
that's okay.
Yep.
Yep. That looks fine.
So that all looks okay.
Added the context. Added the Yep.
And that's go mod. That's very big.
Yep.
Let's go back up here.
Well, Prometheus gone. Hotel n.
Yeah.
Logger. Oh, you remove it you removed a
logger equals logline.
That might be important. That looks important.
Wrong way.
Okay. So Oh, yeah.
That was there before. Right?
I think so. So that's in the gRPC
main. Right? Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Just probably right
up that brace.
Okay. That'll probably get the build build going.
I'm wondering why they chose that in here.
Anyway.
Let's just keep blaming Versus code. Okay.
Alright. It's running.
Alright. Let's make sure that this works.
Yay. Hey.
I'm annoyed that it fails silently if you
don't do that. You know? Like, that that
that really bugs me.
But okay.
Great.
Back to where we were. Our result count
shows up now.
Oh, it does? Yeah.
Okay. So the problem was that it never
compiled after logger equals log disappeared.
So none of our other changes were making
it through. So now we can probably delete
that extra logline because we
Well, let's not delete anything until we get
through this next step. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Let's
go back to the manual spans on the
DB cluster. Let's go to create manual span
from the DB. Okay.
So
which
let's see. Where is that function?
No. That was in hardware, wasn't it? Under
the DB. Okay. So this is where we
wanna add our span. Yep. So first, we
need a trace from context. Yep.
And remember, it's trace dot span from context.
And c t x. Okay. Yep.
And now we need to
set or we need to instantiate a new
span.
So we're going to
if you look at the documentation for for
the trace API
go docs again. Yep.
So look at the type methods on type
span.
Yep.
So to answer the question about what people
are saying earlier about trace logs, right, like,
add event. Right there. Add event. That's where
you would have added a, added your your
contextual logs. But instead of adding event,
what we're doing
sorry. It's answering the previous question of how
you add a lot logs. Here, though, we
need to create a new span.
So there should be a
I should read the docs instead of using
Read read the docs.
I'll I'll be right back.
Yeah. No problem.
Oh, why am I failing to remember how
to how to do this?
So when we call
trace span from context, that's returning a new
span, is it not? Or if I mess
up No. Spanner context returns our current span.
Ah, I remembered the deal. We don't need
we don't actually need to run span from
con or we will need to run span
from context later.
Potentially, no. We don't. Sorry.
The thing that we want is
to get our our trace provider
or trace dot start. Ah, that's it. Trace
dot start.
So something like let me paste it over.
Actually, why don't I can directly edit this,
can't I? Go for it.
Where are we? We're in database? Hardware.com. Hardware.go.
In database. Yeah. Great.
Where are we? Lane 156. Ah,
yes. Perfect.
K. So we want something like this.
So something like this.
Yep. That should do it.
And I hope it automatically inferred. No. It
did not.
So we need to
fix this or if it's not happy about
this.
I think the Versus Code web interface has
some sort of operational transformation bug
because I'm seeing
lots of duplications.
So I'm just Oh, no. I see it
too. Yeah. And it's gonna clean this up.
I think that is where we wanna be.
So I've saved that. Yep. Right? Yeah. Yep.
I'm gonna close my browser then to prevent
oh, no. It it did more of that.
Okay. I'm going to close my browser so
it stops do stops
messing this up.
Yeah.
I think it's okay. I think yeah. We're
we're good now. Okay. I'll look at the
top. Let's make sure my imports are correct.
Nope. That's bad too,
and we need API
trace as well.
Okay. So API
trace.
I think it might be just r slash
hotel slash global, not API
trace.
Okay.
Hotel global and API trace.
I wanna find out what feature that is
so I can make sure I always turn
it off.
Yeah. Delete stuff. It cleans up unused import.
So you have to add this underscore at
the start until you have code that you
need. It is API global. Sorry.
And it is API global. Okay.
Okay.
So
now let's go ahead and add with the
trace. Let's add add in some attributes to
the span. Oh, actually, we don't need the
trace library, I think, because we got the
span automatically. Okay.
So
what would be useful to remember from here?
What do we need?
Length of the query,
maybe the input parameters, like the hardware ID.
But this is get all. So get all.
Okay. So maybe there's just no no useful
info about the span to report. Great. Perfect.
Okay. Let's solder on and see whether we
get the get all span now in in
Honeycomb.
Should we just add something random so we
can see that coming through? I mean, make
it No. This this should make it come
through. Just it'll create just a span named
tink d b dot get all. Right? Okay.
I gotcha. This is creating the shell span.
So Let's check till it's still happy. So
it'll still get us, like, how long the
query took. Right?
Yeah. It'll still get us how long the
query took. So deployed thirty seconds ago. I
can still hit hardware less. So now we
wanna go to Honeycomb, and we should see
this getting a little bit more complicated. Right?
We should have Yep. Multiple.
That is correct. Oh, look. Two two colors.
The database is only half of the time.
That's cool.
Well, I guess there's nothing been returned. So
it's we don't have any hardware.
You have some files ready to add add
some. Right? Yeah. Should we should we should
we instrument add hardware first, or do you
want to just run add hardware? Let's just
add run. We're running a little short on
time. Let's let's let's just insert some things
into the database and now make it a
little bit slower.
I mean, this is per when I was
looking through this code last night, this is
way further than I thought we would get.
So
Honestly,
Versus code slowed us down the most out
of anything here.
Yeah. The share thing is really cool, though.
Well, I hope they keep working on it.
Yeah. I hope they keep working on it.
Okay. So we've just got to run this
command
and,
yep. That's the one. The hardware.
What was it?
Push fail.
Hard.
I think it went in. Oh, okay. I
know.
Ta da. Okay. So the next biblical hardware
list.
Okay. So now let's see what that looks
like in Honeycomb.
It looks the same.
Well, it looks the same, and we should
now see some attributes that are being set.
Like, we should be able to see the
Result count one.
So we we we got a record.
Do we have a result? Oh, we do.
Wait. Yeah. Yeah. And the database is now
the fastest part. So
it's weird. Okay. So that does beg the
question. Right? Like, why is it that the
that's why is it doing so much stuff
in the forty milliseconds before it actually talks
to the database? Right?
This is part of right. Like, instrumentation for
the sake of instrumentation is pointless. Right? Like,
the reason why we do this is to
and hover performance things or things that are
like, That's not doing what I expected it
to. Right? And then you dive in and
debug.
Cool. Well, I think this is probably a
good place to leave leave off and probably
wrap it up. Yeah?
Yeah. Definitely. That was super valuable to me
and up over to everyone else that was
watching. I think Amy and I can have
some fun adding instrumentation to this and try
and work out with that forty milliseconds is
going. But that was awesome. Thank you both
very much for joining me.
That was fun.
Alright. Well Any audience questions?
Oh yeah. If you have questions, you have
a few minutes to get them in
and we'll try our best to tackle them.
Didn't think was very happy. Think. In my
name.
Oh,
so much for So we've got a thank
you, that was really great. Thank you Jacob.
Another thank you from Mike. Thank you, Mike.
And we did answer the question earlier, didn't
we? Yes we did.
I think we're great.
Great.
Awesome thanks for tuning in.
Easier. That was a lot easier from the
point of view of importing OpenTelemetry
and getting started. The challenges we had were
completely unrelated which was frustrating but we got
there and then so thank
you both for joining me. Have an absolutely
great day and that was a pleasure. Thanks.